unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see
how the political biases of different
sources are influencing the news
you read download the free ground news
app and browser extension
at davidpakman.com ground
a quick story about donald trump's press
secretary and
senior adviser to the trump campaign
kaylee mcinanni
has now entered a complete and total
fantasy world where up is down
day is night and i guess stupid is smart
now
in the real world where i believe most
of you live
joe biden won the election with the
votes he garnered on november 3rd
and then those votes translated
into electoral votes last monday
december 14th
when electors in all 50 states met in
accordance
with the results in each state casting
their electoral votes
for joe biden to have 306 electoral
votes
that's the process by which joe biden
won
in kaylee mcinanny's alternate universe
listen to what she came up with what is
the update now
that we're at this late date in terms of
the challenges and other states and
investigations that are ongoing
yeah there's still ongoing litigation in
arizona there are a few other appeal
options in nevada and elsewhere so the
president's litigation is ongoing make
make no mistake
also in the four states that we saw a
lot of problems in with those big metro
areas the only metro areas where joe
biden beat hillary clinton ironically
in those states there has been an
alternate slate of electors voted upon
that congress will decide
in january so we will see what happens
ongoing litigation
this president's a fighter he's not
giving up he will fight for the
forgotten men
so she tells fox news propagandist sean
hannity
that not only is there litigation going
on
but alternate electors voted on december
14th
as well even in states where joe biden
officially won
and officially got electoral votes if
republicans believe
trump really won that state a second
slate of republican electors also voted
for trump
and as far as kaylee wants you to
believe a court
is going to decide or mike pence will
decide on january 6
which electors to count alright it looks
like biden won
and democratic electors voted for biden
but mike pence could
choose to recognize an alternate slate
of republican electors
this is a grift this is a grif that's it
some of you may have actually heard that
there were such alternate electors in
some states michigan pennsylvania some
other states
it's not untrue if you don't understand
what it means to be an elector
uh it it is untrue because these
so-called al
alternate electors aren't actually
electors in any legal sense
so what happened was that a bunch of
republicans
appointed themselves alternate electors
it's a term that doesn't exist there's
no such thing as an alternate elector
it's not like a jury where you have 12
people on the jury and
two alternate jurors who listen to the
evidence and they're ready
if a juror should fall ill no the
they they did nothing of legal meaning
they appointed themselves electors
and they cast votes for trump in a
meaningless unofficial exercise
mike pence in the joint session on
january 6th
he simply counts electoral votes mike
pence doesn't
get to say well i've got 16 democratic
electoral votes from georgia
and 16 republican electoral votes let me
choose which ones to accept
it doesn't work that way it's a fantasy
world
and kaylee is spreading this fantasy on
fox news
and it probably does lead to trumpists
continuing to donate cash to trump but
it's fake
these electors are electors only in the
sense that i could call up my high
school classmates and say guys
let's get together and cast alternate
votes as electors
what it's it's meaningless guys let's
get together and then
mike pence or the supreme court will
decide do they count
those electors or do they count us it's
fake
it's absurd it's ridiculous and people
are actually being scammed out of money
if they believe it thinking let's keep
donating because they're gonna
fight up up until i guess the supreme
court
to try to get these alternate electors
votes counted it's just fake
you're falling for something that
doesn't exist um
maybe i shouldn't be that worried about
trump is getting scammed
but i want to make sure it's clear that
this is a complete and total fantasy
we'll have more about this on our
instagram page you can find the show on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
you can find me on instagram
david.pakman